ich habe mich gefreut und zwar über den
niederländischen bundescoach louis
shanghai als er gestern beim spiel gegen
das dfb team fast beiläufig erklärte es
sei immer noch positiv sei begann die
anwesenden deutschen journalisten eifrig
zu tusche wie kann das denn sein was
macht ihr hier doch für mich hat van hal
alles richtig gemacht lassen sie es mich
ihnen erklären sein pr pcr test ist zwar
positiv aber sein arzt hätten gesagt
dass es nur reste erscheinungen sind die
schnelltests von franke waren alle
negativ
ergo der mann ist gesund und hat sich
völlig regelkonform verhalten in den
niederlanden geht darüber hinaus dass
einer krone erkrankt da nach fünf tagen
aus der quarantäne darf wenn er keine
symptome mehr ausfalls und wie schön war
von heizung haben mit unserem thomas
müller wie schön ist es endlich wieder
menschen zu sehen gesunde menschen die
nicht mit angst einander begegnen
sondern mit freude anstatt also dass wir
verurteilen und darüber tuscheln warum
er jetzt mit einem noch positiven gruner
pcs an diesem spiel teilnimmt finde ich
wir sollten uns im vorbild nehmen
gesunde menschen müssen raus ins leben
wie sehen sie das
ehrlich gesagt ist das zurzeit nicht
meine allergrößte sorge erstens habe ich
nichts übrig im fußball zwei zentralen
in meinem alter also ich finde er sollte
sich schonen und übrigens mir jeder
münchen partie strenge quarantäne ist
mit oder ohne symptome das erhöht die
zahl der verfügbaren parkplätze
[Gelächter]
es war so diplomatische antwort ja
bruder ich weiß gar nicht was ich darauf
antworte ich erweitere die runde einfach
weil ich schätze dass boris palmer der
uns ja live aus typisch sind so gescheit
ist mir wieder sprechen wird und
diskussion belebt ja immer die
unterhaltung in der fall war
nee da täuschen sie sich ich finde in
der tat dass wir dahin kommen müssen
dass menschen die krank sind zu hause
bleiben und menschen die gesund sind
wieder am leben teilnehmen können die
pandemie ist zwar nicht rum aber wir
können auch nicht ewig so weiter machen
dass wir bei jedem pc hat es die leute
aus dem verkehr
frau dr klein ich freue mich zwar so
viel zuspruch aber wie ist ihre meinung
ich bin mir da tatsächlich nicht so
sicher also ich teile die euphorie nicht
denn wenn wir eins wissen über corona
ist dass wir im grunde genommen immer
noch nicht so viel wissen und wir wissen
einfach nicht kommt es zu mutationen
vielleicht nochmal wie entwickelt sich
die pandemie insofern bin ich da eher
ein bisschen vorsichtiger und wäre
tatsächlich dafür dass wir bei pcr test
positiv ergebnissen doch noch mal ein
bisschen abstand halten und das
schrittweise angehen
ich bin auch sagen wir mal eher
skeptisch und und würde jetzt louis van
gaal nicht unbedingt zu jubeln für die
für das was hat er gemacht hat alles was
gesagt wird stimmt wir müssen zur
normalität zurück aber bei einem mann
der so in der öffentlichkeit steht ist
es ja auch ein symbol als er sagt damit
ich habe den positiven test aber kümmere
mich halt nicht richtig darum sondern
ich bin gesund und ich kann jetzt machen
was ich will ich fürchte dass das bei
menschen die nicht so unter
gesundheitlicher kontrolle sind wie
leistungssportler und deren trainer wo
man auf die expertise des arztes quasi
in jeder minute zurückgreifen kann dass
manche leute daraus vielleicht den
falschen schluss ziehen und sagen jetzt
ist wieder alles mit jedem möglich und
wo ich huste und spucke und habe auch
schon ein bisschen fieber aber ich kann
jetzt trotzdem mit dem busfahrer umarmen
das wäre dann ein fatales signal
deswegen ist es so ich habe heute auch
schon ganzen tag überlegt wie ich das
finden soll eine sehne ich mich danach
dass genau diese szenen wieder die
normalität werden andererseits habe ich
schon so ein leichtes stöhr gefühl
vor dem hintergrund der vorbildfunktion
hättest du denn lust wenn du symptomfrei
werft zehn tage quarantäne zu gehen ich
glaube dass das die eigentliche
mitgelieferter symptomfreiheit die
eigentliche mitgelieferte botschaft
glaube ich kann mir von boris palmer die
quarantäne regeln machen den unterschied
also wir müssen eigentlich dazu kommen
quarantäne für symptomlose menschen
selbst bei positiven test abzuschaffen
andere länder haben es geschafft aber
symptomlose menschen können immer noch
andere anstalt ja mir ist das klar aber
das würde ich sagen ist dass das ein
lebensrisiko das restrisiko es ist ein
lebensrisiko ein restrisiko restrisikos
gemein
der stand von atommeilern und
unrichtig möglicherweise gesagt wenn sie
in die luft fliegen aber ich glaube dass
das wir uns hier das sagen der maßstab
also solange es der alte atommeiler
nicht so leichtes cara den regeln gibt
kommen wir nicht zurück in die freiheit
aber es gab so viele sachen die in
dieser situation vollkommen albern sind
wissen sie ich bin neulich versehentlich
ein flugzeug geflogen ich saß so da was
natürlich bei meiner größe kein großes
problem ist aber auch erwachsene
menschen saßen so dass sie würden leyen
und die leute stiften und schnupfen und
hatten alle masken an und ich hätte
gerne die maske abgenommen und dann beim
aussteigen hieß es achten sie bitte auf
den abstand ja das war der moment wo ich
mich fragte die wollen einen verarschen
oder eine vieles vieles wird immer
unverständlich und wissen sie bei den
beiden flüchten würde jetzt
ist die haben irgendwie auch nicht auf
den abstand geachtet als sie in chemnitz
laufen bahnsteig standen also was soll
es dann und wenn es in berlin eine demo
gibt dann hängt der einsatz der polizei
davon ab für oder gegen wen die demo ist
und die einen dürfen masken tragen die
anderen können und die anderen können
machen was sie wollen das ist sehr viel
taktik dabei um nicht zu sagen
politischer ranschmeißen also wenn ein
ergebnis dieser phase sein sollte dass
man beliebig mit unterschiedlicher lms
kann in einem rechtsstaat dann ringt
gekommen nein dann haben wir dann haben
wir wirklich longo wird dann ist dass
wir gleich lang und hat eine haben wir
lankowitz der bruder und herr strunz war
eigentlich festgestellt haben
nein also ich finde erst einmal die
kirche im dorf lassen klar sind viele
regeln nicht bis ins letzte logisch war
schon gefragt jetzt muss ich zwei
stunden die maske tragen die indoor
veranstaltung mit abstand aber danach
ist es erlaubt dass alle die maske
ausziehen wenn man gemeinsam zum buffet
geht und dann dort zusammen steht was
hat es denn gebracht in der
veranstaltung die maske da gebe ich
ihnen schon recht dass es nicht bis zur
ebene alles logisch und stricken aber
das ganze ist halt auch unvollkommen und
sicherlich nicht widerspruchsfrei wir
irgendwie versuchen verhalten zu
reglementieren
es kann der staat nur sowieso nur ganz
bedingt und dann muss man sich damit
abfinden dass ist da halt auch zu
einfach ein bisschen albern etwas
widersprüchlich und sachen kommt das
bedeutet nicht dass die absicht dahinter
steckt sondern dass keiner bessere
vorschläge gefunden hat natürlich ist es
absicht die frage ist nun wie sie
absicht definieren es ist nicht die
absicht die leute zu etwas zu zwingen
aber es ist nur aus die absicht ein
klima zu schaffen das von angst regiert
wird und das hat auch prima funktioniert
und inzwischen sehe ich nicht nur bei
rtl aber vor allem dort verzweifelt der
menschen die sagen sie möchten die maske
anbehalten ja sie fühlen sich dann
irgendwie besser es gibt inzwischen
wunderbare artikel in feuilletons dass
die maske zur schönheit der erscheinung
beiträgt weil man sich als sicherer als
es gibt jetzt schon diese test ist wenn
ich meine maske trägt man das sich
selbst als sicherer und den anderen als
empathischer ja ja ja was gleich zwei
illusion und auf einmal vielleicht liegt
es aber daran weil man sich gesund fühlt
was ich ja ganz ganz spannend fand aber
hast du das ist ja mal sagen wenn die
leute den schluss ziehen sie wollen
weiter maske treiber sollen sie halt
weiter was getragen so lang nicht daraus
folgt dass ich auch gerne tragen muss
also das fände ich sozusagen also
geeignet um sich darüber lustig zu
machen wenn man anderer meinung ist aber
jetzt als jeder nach seiner fasson
eigentlichen schritt in die richtige
richtung gerade bei der maske naja wer
sich damit sicherer fühlt so soll es
doch maria stört niemanden sie möchten
auch nicht aus denn wir angehörige von
fkk club bei edeka laden ein aber die
haben mir weniger an die mir damals kam
er dann ein ich finde wenn es regnen
wenn uns regeln gibt sollten regeln
schon verbindlich sein für alle nein ich
meine bewerbung
da bin ich nicht ob sie missverstanden
er sei missverstanden dass ich ihn
verstanden
ich glaub ja also die meine überlegung
setzt jahren wenn es keine masken
pflicht mehr gibt muss ist ja trotzdem
jemanden freigestellt sein eine zu
tragen ja es gibt ja auch keine hut
pflicht und trotzdem sehe ich manchmal
leute mit hüten rumlaufen das ist ein
sehr gutes bild ab morgen ist es von
ich denke was das beispiel einfach zeigt
dass das war eine ganz große sehnsucht
einfach vorhanden ist nach normalität
auch ein stück weit nach mehr
herzlichkeit ein bisschen mehr
miteinander und das ist auch sehr
verständlich nach zwei jahren pandemie
dennoch muss ich das zurückweisen dass
sie gesagt haben dass wir ein klima der
angst schaffen wollen das ist mitnichten
so es geht natürlich um den schutz der
bevölkerung und wir haben es hier
einfach mit einer pandemie zu tun immer
noch auch und nicht mit einer grippe und
das ist für einen schutz der bevölkerung
hält das ehepaar sein eigenheim verlässt
300 meter zum zigarettenautomaten geht
und wieder zurück und daraufhin jeweils
500 euro strafe zahlen nicht dahinter
steckt nicht die idee des schutzes der
bevölkerung
das ist oftmals auch widersprüchlich ist
gebe ich zu das ist so auch wenn ich mir
selber nicht dafür verantwortlich bin
für diese regelung dennoch ist die
politische vorstellungen genau und aber
dennoch die politik muss natürlich
gucken und flexibel auf die neue
situation reagieren und
wir waren und so kommt der politik auch
eine versuchsanordnung ganz zu pass
nicht wahr wenn mit hochschrauben leute
von stränden verjagt werden wissen sie
oder wenn ein 17-jähriger quer durch in
hamburger park von einem streifenwagen
gejagt wird dann glaube ich nicht dass
es wirklich zeichen der fürsorge sind
das ist eine versuchsanordnung
sicherheit nicht bösartig nummer eins ja
alle gut meine sagen sie mir jemanden
ist nicht gut meint
vielleicht putin damals wahrscheinlich
nicht gut aber ansonsten hat es schon
großen charakter von einen großen zug
von social engineering gehabt und es gab
ganz viele situationen wo man wirklich
ausprobieren konnte wie weit man leute
durch die vermittlung von angst bringen
kann das hat funktioniert also dass auch
das weil ich zurück dass wir hier social
engineering betreiben in der politik das
ist einfach nicht der fall ist die
grundlage der politik der ok also wir
versuchen einfach auf die situation zu
reagieren um die bevölkerung bestmöglich
zu schützen und dann geht es
insbesondere auch um die wohlhabenden
gruppen um die risikogruppen um die
ältere generation habe schon sie mich
dabei
mehr noch schwere verläufe hat und
deswegen es geht um den schutz da bleibe
ich dabei ja ich habe meine solidarische
kollektion hinter mir